les chenilles pas malade il est souvent
malmené suis pas bien elle n'échoue et
fabienne parquet sous les plaintes
sexuelle viennent du tout que les wade
sont menées mais ferrer n caillou voix
des femmes c'est normal ne me fait rien
elle vous tailler un jour il fait beau
il fait du soleil mais sam viennent
m'aider la halle avec ou non rien ne
connaît pas une différence alors y était
à laboratoire sexuelle il a examiné
il s'appelle as expérience sous la
grenouille vivante la clape ou remords
sais pas quoi ma vie annonciation n'est
feriel rien du tout ou rien du tout je
ne peux pas rester concert pour qui nous
dépasse et donner des prêts ça nous ont
aidés à venise sous les plantes sexuelle
si vous le plan de la santé ben ali ne
suis ni bien ni mal il serait normal
machou le flash sexuelle mac et mac et
s'il n'y a pas la cimade à mort s'il n'y
a pas la section ma la section madone la
pression l' obsession sexuelle
la madame edith équipes têtes devaient
aller 1 à l'aller si tu lâches sexuelle
par les employés de maison madame effet
rien n'est matériel l'article amazon
dissiper cette devait la cousine
aphrodisiaques un gault et millau a
service de l'amour tous les riches est
née mérienne oui elle vit en rien la
madame est par là tout le temps d ou
normes qui peut me faire le bienne où
l'espagnol qui je ne connais pas marlon
brando danseurs de tango à paris
la crispation c'est pas marrant
heureusement pour la première fois en
france à remède efficace contre la
crispation maladie qui fait des ravages
quelques temps dans le monde entier
vient d'être apporté des us
c'est un petit sifflet magique véritable
remède miracle pour vous en prouver
l'efficacité nous l'avons essayée sur
plusieurs personnes particulièrement
crispé d'ailleurs regardez vous même
bonsoir madame ou mademoiselle les
bouche à bouche bien ce soir mais ta
partie la délicate mission de vous
éclairer sur les motivations au néo
cartésienne de la dialectique
démocratique alors dans un premier temps
et bien ou très trop de l'affluence
géophysique du climat sur
l'idiosyncrasie du chef d'état et que
nous amènera à formuler une analyse
complète du pouvoir politique et le
pouvoir politique chassant vachard via
ces faits de tout petit ria ça se passe
est un peu chiante et ça revient ça sur
kaka belfort folk pop bible est alors
loin des bols à l'épaule j'ai ça
devenait père les clodettes en fait
c'est patrick tort jughurta julio pas me
tenir ici de l'apa patapédia alors
jughurta plus du retard de la patinoire
la liste est vous allez faites me dire
que c'est pas si c'est qu'il a décoincé
qu'il était déjà vachement libéré bon
alors c'est pour cette raison que nous
sommes allés renouveler l'expérience
chez un autre personnage à ces sujets à
la crispation
il est inadmissible que d'autres pays
comme la france qui se réclament depuis
la nuit des temps la liberté
d'expression nous soyons j'ai fait aux
dénoue les socialistes un système
totalitaire d'un four tenue clients d'un
supermarché tentaculaire à la
consommation forcée d'une politique qui
nous révulse qui est temps de cesser ce
grand commerce gouvernementale pour
vivre un autre idéal libres de toute
pression
et bien sachez mesdames approchez
approchez les belles marveaux et les
fraises garantie sans épines
approchez mesdames du spectacle pour
marcher une pétale pour massa et une
totale pourra car après les frais
vous allez peut-être me dire maintenant
que l'essai n'est pas concluant que ses
volte face n'ont rien d'étonnant de la
part d'hommes politiques qui sont avant
tout de grands comédiens pour vous
convaincre voici un dernier essai tenté
sur une personnalité internationale
vachement stable sacem des pôles si les
drom du phalère au total 13 ans qu'un
tas de la bonne parole quant aux écoles
de choristes rallye dani nevo mon fleuve
d'amour genou
arrivé de toulouse auch la terre et la
belgique notamment
[Applaudissements]
nous avions ce petit il est magique qui
descoings est en vente exclusivement à
la ssp où on rencontre maintenant des
gens absolument adorable où règne une
ambiance hyper décontracté mais revoilà
cas de bon sens a fait une heure que je
te le dis en france on dit toujours la
culture la culture
elie bonne mais je me souviens autrefois
chez mon grand-père il y avait accroché
dans le salon
3 mené 3-2 galles 3 renoir de
somptueuses tapisseries
dieu merci c'est moi qui ont hérité
après beaucoup de discussions et bien
qu'ils aient tous tes chaque jour ses
magnifiques tableaux c'étaient les
bonnes
il y avait de quoi leur forme et me
semble scellée par semaine deux sens et
les fautes et les canapés louis saez ou
la splendide bibliothèque remontée moi
mon oreiller eugénie cette analyse et
l'argenterie cristaux les bibelots libye
joue c'était pas de la culture une leçon
d'art incomparable dont elle bénéficiait
gracieusement sans débourser un centime
et les conversations à table
sir fx étincelante de l'élite dont elle
pouvait saisir des bribes on vole tout
en présentant les plats c'était pas de
la culture ballon laissez moi rire
voulez-vous me dire ce qu'elles font à
présent elle travaille à l'usiné où elle
fera quand apporte quoi des portugais
elle se traîne dans le métro presse
d'élèves de la marmaille je souhaite
bien du plaisir et elle habite sur le
demande en banlieue c'est agréable dans
un seuil hlaing tellement hideuse que
moi passant devant le refus de les voir
au lieu de loge dans une de ses chambres
de service pour char à chaque mais nord
et qu'on loue trek prague elle était
étudiant charme elle ne voulait plus de
nos champs mais bien nous avons reprises
ouah je vois dans mon immeuble
l'ailé tout rafler et genlis un
appartement x philippins sont très
amusants qui ravit tous amis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est moi comme ça juste diane 1
à 16h20 la langue c'est cher c'est parce
que tu es totalement rose et pro vie à
cause de ma drogue douce
j'ai dû dire je viens d parce que je
suis pas insensible au magazine id id
actuelle marceau farceur leurs roses ça
demandera contrat sita vulgaire génial
je préfère que tu me dis dans mes
camarades ou même le des russes
j'ai horreur de la vulgarité il est
arrivé et pique à cyano et des pickups
même j'ai décidément bien c'est un bon
gars et ça me dit ça ma porte à clé des
zones à peu de temps total à fort sur
ses mains fils et sa femme a même su
elle aurait voulu parler c'était
peut-être l'ancien s'étourdissant par
achiou quelqus et puis je vous faisais
pas ce qui me retient comme un jardin
qu'on n'appelle pas de produits dismas
de la presse un film d'après kata bien
josiane junte un barouf tient temps où
parler que c'est un genre demeurent
prier à st
jeudi mme sais pas mais qu'est ce que
j'ai de venir je suis toute seule dans
ma vie de chat heureusement pas
l'interview de travail lors d'un match
ça chantait sais pas si je vais rester
puceau zhejiang chose d'attendu pas un
4x
il m'a remis une activité de la
comprendre ce plan alors est ce que tu
dis demain donc je me dis vaut un jaune
lac l'accord de vacances chose
maintenant je vous rappeler de l'ofj
avait cédé un choix de papier j'ai passé
des nuits blanches jusqu'à 7 heures sur
mon lit il va comme sur place alors que
la révocation la patronne et si vous
n'avez pas à raconter votre client
j'étais un boulet généralement ça m'a
boosté jeudi mais enfin jamie damon est
temps de faire mon travail c'est un
brushing aux fauteuils roulants
tu vas bien vu que ce bien ma barbe y
est c'est vrai c'est pas qu'il a mené
qu'une mince
c'est que j'ai toujours aussi dans de
jolis moi je craque ça ne passera pas
j'ai entendu dire qu'il avait déjà dit
que créer vos vedettes
alors je lui si vous croisez vous n'êtes
pas c'est vrai quoi j'ai pas pu masquer
une note
c'est une lettre c'est que je te dise
que j ennemis ça veut dire c'est merci à
papier tiens ça fait drôlement bien pigé
pas payer cher tintin monoprix sa
gaspésie ennemis et nuit a dit non c'est
pas moi c'est la meilleure de l'année
je sais pas si c'est la chaleur ou quoi
mais je suis quand même en fait taire ce
moment oui si ça me revient que dans un
vivier venu pour commencer mon génie je
t'aime mon génie je te veux c'est ce
qu'elle a mises oscillent entre
parenthèses jonnhy ton sexe je ne sais
pas où tu avais marre mais seulement je
te veux aussi quant aux réserves et
c'est jenny comme thiébaut on sera qui
dépose ce travail passe des mois ses 105
hitachi je contrôle pur
j'aime y aussi ta liberté c'est mon
bonheur ça c'est beau comme formule
marche pas trouvé comme ça j'ai réfléchi
je suis une pac ne sera pas que c'est
toute façon pourquoi que je ne va pas
arranger les dents parce que mon fiancé
dit que c'est ça qui fait son charme
[Musique]
oui car pendant tout le spectacle je me
gratte je me gratte c'est tout enfin
quand je dis c'est tout c'est énorme
naturellement c'est très violent très
engagé comme tous quelque chose dans la
pièce à je suis une bourgeoise où est
bien sûr une bourgeoise ça c'est herman
exprimé par l'odeur de boules puantes
projette dans la salle dès le début
ainsi chaque soir au moment où ils
entrent en scène une idée de trucs le
vétéran l'espace fantastique
vous saisissez l'équation le raccourci
j'arrive je pu donc je suis une
bourgeoise c'est fabuleux
alors naturellement chez nikon incapable
de prononcer les mots mais une conne bus
gratte parce qu'elle est conne parce
qu'elle se sent mal dans sa peau
parce que parce qu'enfin tout c'est
fantastique
1h30 2h 2h30 je sais pas peu importe je
dis on s'en fout ça va tellement plus
loin à ligne ont fait durer quatre
heures
ça aurait pu durer toute la nuit a
peut-être durer toute l'année je ne sais
pas je ne sais plus j'en suis là entre
le public et moi
vic très jeune très chouette il y avait
une telle complicité une telle
connivence terre en plastique
je me suis mêlé à eux aux jeunes comme
ça simplement d'un seul coup j'ai eu
envie c'est pas sympa c'est très
chouette et vraiment ça a été très
chouette
j'étais là au milieu d'eux il y avait
une telle chaleur un tel contact à la
fin tout le monde se grattait tout le
monde grapel toulon et même un moyen d'y
pisser pardon à la rentrée a voulu bien
sur je créé la nouvelle pièce de choses
le troisième volet de sa trilogie
alors là je crois qu'il est difficile
d'aller plus loin je te les 10 ans
tutoie je sais plus si un citoyen très
flou c'est le troisième volet tu voit
l'aboutissement c'est assez terrifiant
mais si tu veux j'ai essayé de te dire
enfin c'est pas facile alors je suis là
bourgeoise bien sûr mais arrivé au
dernier stade tu vois à poil
complètement à poil
très belle tu vois mais un intérieur
complètement pourrie elle est là à poil
et puis un jeune qui passe à poils très
chouette très dur très dur cet hiver
n'est pas tout de suite et il me trash
enfin dans la gueule et durant toute la
pièce
tu vois on assiste à la descente du son
depuis les yeux jusqu'au c'est énorme ce
voleur cette arrivée de la salive en
fait que les cicatrices
[Rires]
et avant cette lente descente celle
angoisse le malaise
si tu veux je me suis parlons d'autre
chose je me sens pas très bien c'est un
rôle qui engage terriblement c'est un
rôle très très lourd à assumer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous entendez au cediv après ça tout le
reste les mondanités cocktails et robes
du soir les général et qui était la côte
d'azur saint tropez c'est intolérable
il y en a ras-le-bol ras-le-bol
ras-le-bol cette année jean et moi on
n'en pouvait plus on a fui jusqu en
auvergne au fin fond du cantal une ferme
au bout d'un village d'une saleté d'une
bosse et dément les femmes en noir sans
âge et dante est partante encore des
seaux d'eau le visage creusé ravagé
sillonné comme la terre génitrice
convient de labourer les vieux paysan
immobile sur leur banc de pierre moussu
ne prononçant pas un mot pendant des
journées entières lançant seulement de
temps à autre le jet de rue des salines
comme on jette sa semence
c'est d'un pathétique et d'une
authenticité souvent jean et moi de nous
regardions et nous disions mais c'est
pas possible ça existe encore mais c'est
merveilleux fois profité très vite
s'énerver et puis un soir
ce soir là je ne suis pas prêt de
l'oublier jean est tombé dans le tape
huniers ivars le chemin conduisant à la
ferme
je l'attendais j'étais à table comme le
chat affamé jeu là près du lait bourru
en écoutant à la mélopée nostalgiques
des moutons revenant du pâturage
lorsque j'en ai 113,7 hauts de seine
jeudi à georges tzipine ne fait pas un
pas qui je ne le supporterais pas
c'était trop trop d'un seul coup je me
suis levé mon coeur battait violemment
le petit à petit je me suis approché
deux jours je l'aimais longuement je
crois bien que j'ai pleuré et des agents
tu te rends compte ya seulement huit
jours nos vêtements s'entête encore
l'essence la poussière la ville
l'horreur et maintenant six ans mais
c'est ça la vérité jean mon chéri nous
tenons la vérité
je défaille est
il m'a serré très fort contre lui il a
posé sa main puis censure- ma croûte et
ma vie vient une voix sourde et animale
il m'entraîne et de l'autre je me suis
laissée happer par les clameurs indécent
de cette chaude nuit d'été avec mes
sabots mal hongre paysanne en coton bleu
délavé le trébuchet dans la boue ils
purent 1 c'était beau nous avons
traversé l'écurie respirer ses senteurs
il m'a semblé que j'étais ivre
nous avons hâte à la grange dont il a
ouvert la porte il m'a poussé dans ce
coin de tout coup c'est dehors dedans ce
n'était qu'au mieux non j'ai uniquement
allaitement de bell en russe
[Musique]
quand nous nous sommes relevés jean et
moi après deux ou trois saillie n'a pas
eu tout mêlé à mes cheveux les faits et
un autre oiseau intime avec une
certitude
à partir de cet instant plus rien ne
sera comme avant
désormais je ne pourrai plus faire
l'amour
ce soir
mais 82 un an déjà que les roses sont au
pouvoir
qu'évoque pour vous cet anniversaire
nous sommes allés le demandent et madame
du château pâtissière à boucle sur mer
nous on aime notre métier mon mari les
pâtissiers moi je suis à la caisse pour
nous un même si aujourd'hui on a la lex
devant la plage et qu'on fait des bonnes
saisons avec l'écho faut pas oublier que
joël et moi quand on a démarré en avait
pas et maintenant faut dire ce qui est
on n'est pas bon pour pourquoi
pourquoi
parce que comme la gauche est passé
nos fonds de commerce
adios
tous les coups d'état sont analysés
les blues fantaisie les petits bonnets
très avenant les mules à pompons tout ce
qui fait la vraie pas d'hier
bye bye
tout le monde en gris souris on sera pas
à son avantage
- pas trompé
son cv
d'ailleurs dès maintenant se décider
comme la gauche est passé les
certificats de baptême des gosses
tout ça
dans le four à pain à l'espace tous les
gars tout genre mariages communions
baptêmes 33
hb ne plus prendre eric giler feu je
préfère rater des ventes aujourd'hui que
de risquer de me faire des lendemains
pour des bêtises comme la gauche et
j'avais passé avec joël deux soirs on
travaille la pâte d'amande
croyez moi c'est pas commode enfin
heureusement ça commence à rendre on a
line in au bolchoï montée surgit noise
qui est au poil
mais joël a encore beaucoup de boulot
avec la pièce montée car elle marque sa
cheval sur le kremlin
c'est la barbe en chantilly au bout de
20 minutes
saab et gringore à 100 et du travail
mais comme dit joël comme la gauche est
passé pour mieux être du côté du marteau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes un bon jour c'est pas chaud ce
matin qu'elle cache madame collin du
gris paul a aussi quelque chose ceci la
troisième vente que je rate ce matin
j'étais complètement des validé cette
semaine j'ai plus rien par contre j'ai
un produit nouveau le ghana star et
idylis tricolore en boxer 200 g
personnellement je conseillerais plutôt
la boîte kg je prends ce moment aux
promotions une paire de lunettes de
soleil avec alors dit bonjour adams et
casteljaloux
non madame collin le gamin ça vous tente
pas assez bizarre en général vous prenez
tout ce que je vous propose c'est sur ce
projet soit pas finie la promotion c'est
surtout pour vous un gie pharmacienne
suis pas une fille sierre non on va
madame collin sans rancune bonjour
madame arthur installez vous avec les
autres chez la boue et toi mon petit
gars descendre la bascule mon petit
bonhomme tu vas l'abîmé qu'est-ce-qui
très plaisir
tu sais pas quand j'entame un comité
dessous de 3 4 6 6 1 quand la petite
monnaie j'aime pas ça les petites pièces
moi c'est vrai quoi si pharmacienne suis
pas épicier
bon des comprimés de 8,5 sur la
mandarine thème pains mandarine
c'est pour faire une blague et un copain
abadie le mon petit gars jouent pas le
deviner un temps voire un ses cinquante
six un tel qu'un petit forme ça lui fera
gonfler la 7e rang de méchant tu veux
pas que ça vu moi tu pourrais faire
parler coucou coucou coop ça pendant
huit jours avec le beckham un bon tu
décides mon petit gars j'ai pas perdre
ma journée pour une vente à 6,50 un
bacille 10e sur au sud rue ces sucres et
1h28 avant sa limonade et va transférer
cinq jours de suite oui alors en avant
pour le sirop subdray les fils qu avec
les 40 centimes non mais tu sais lire
y a pas écrit épicière bon allez saute
sur la bascule lui dire combien tu fais
normalement c'est 50 centimes entre 25
et 30 kg se dira les grands continuent à
voir les 10 centimes croire que j
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonjour et 6 et mozart fait à temps il
est 10 heures 5 et nous commençons tout
de suite autre vente choc
aujourd'hui je vous propose un joli lot
j'ai surtout pensé à vous mesdames dans
un sac plastique je fourre 6 abdominaux
balèze parfois 90-79 premier 215
calmez-vous calme une boîte familiale de
s'associer aux histoires instant car ils
35 francs au lieu de 40
une grosse pelletée de comprimés gélules
ampoules caché pilule divers et
multicolore en vrac 6 francs plus de 400
m de bandages divers bande tulle grave
en avant entre mansle alors baissé
leur facture de pâma de parricide tout
ça dans un joli sac plastique vendée
sacrifier au prix incroyable de 175
francs alors dit dépêchons-nous je n'ai
pas que ça à faire
madame sentir heureuse madame droval
docteur tout cas bravo donc encore une
belle van damme et messieurs je vous
remercie au revoir
la plantureuse bac s qui veut procéder
comme ça vous était intéressé a pas de
raison excusez moi j'ai pas vu votre
signe de main l'avant si vous êtes
intéressé agité bien votre petit drapeau
à croix rouge merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]